so we've gone over our four basic uh
postulates and now I have a little
another table here where I'm just
numbering the four different uh effects
again and I'm I'm numbering them in this
way because in some sense it's like a
staircase for some of these you can't
really have one without having the one
under so you can't have superposition
without some label for your space of
States that's that again is is uh
discrete for for the system in the box
that we saw
and you can't have entanglement without
having superposition because
entanglement is just a many body version
of superposition uncertainty you can
kind of have
either way that one doesn't really
matter so on the top here I have sort of
the four big paradigms of quantum
Technologies they're sort of organized
into three actually so one is sensing or
Metrology or Imaging
and everything is quantum so we prefix
Quantum to everything the other one is
cryptography or communication and the
third one is Computing the fourth one
here is appended as simulation
and I'll get into that a little bit more
but I guess I want to emphasize here
that historically
the primary Quantum effect that has been
utilized in Technologies has been the
first one the bottom one discreteness
and super and in some sense
superposition
and uh the later effects the so the
later Technologies are the ones that
utilize these other effects because
these other effects are much difficult
to distill and to uh utilize in Quantum
systems because Quantum systems are so
fragile
so if we go back in time a little bit
the first technology that that utilized
uh this discreteness of energy levels or
that requires discreetness to describe
um is NMR nuclear magnetic resonance so
this was one of the earliest uses of
quantum technology is another one is the
laser resistance standard atomic clock
principle of uncertainty helped us
detect gravitational waves and nowadays
if we go to sort of more
state-of-the-art we have something
called Quantum Imaging where there's
several different technologies that are
utilized to enhance the your current
known Imaging standards like pet NMR
as well as create new ones using some of
these Quantum systems that are more
relevant to the Computing side
and collectively you can call this
Quantum Imaging or Quantum Metrology
and there's very many different
proposals here that are still actively
studied up to date so that's basically
Metrology I want to emphasize that it's
the most sort of longest studied
Paradigm here for the application of
these effects the next one is uh
cryptography or communication
uh if we go back now
uh and remember our principle of
collapse
we can imagine that we could design a
protocol for communication that would be
sensitive to eavesdroppers
namely if we could somehow utilize
quantum mechanics in a way that an
eavesdropper could be detected using
this principle of collapse
maybe we have a way to protect ourselves
from eavesdroppers and such a protocol
does exist uh it's the the the Pres this
this requires basically all four
different Technologies and hence it was
not realized until a little bit later
the use of quantum mechanics here is
during these What's called the key
generation stage of this protocol so in
order for us to communicate securely we
need to generate a key to generate this
key we need to make sure the
eavesdropper doesn't know it and we can
utilize quantum mechanics to utilize
entanglement and uncertainty to in
superposition to generate a key such
that both
you know you and the communicating party
know the key
but any eavesdropper that comes in and
tries to intercept the key as you're
generating it will get caught because of
the collapse principles of quantum
mechanics
now I can't the reason I have to use
this scheme is that if I just send you
the key on an on the initial
communication line
that's assumed unencrypted the
eavesdropper will just know the E
because the initial line is unencrypted
so we have to encrypt it but to encrypt
it we have to generate a key in a way
that thieves dropper doesn't
gain access to it and using quantum
mechanics we can do so in a way that if
a needs dropper tries to access it we
will know and we can stop hey there's
many different commercial devices that
do this and the state-of-the-art key
distribution has been done in order
hundreds or thousands of kilometers in
both Optical fibers and in free space
communication
so that's hence this
line here we mentioned several different
uh Technologies here
they're basically utilizing small
Quantum systems one two atoms
um
not very many but I told you that
entanglement here is a property that is
present not just for two particles but
you can write States like this with two
commas for three particles four
particles Etc and you can have something
called many body entanglement and the
more particles you include the harder it
is to control
but the more particles you include the
more different possibilities of States
you can have now let's say each article
each subsystem has two states and this
means when you add a subsystem
you double the number of states because
each one can be in two states so here
this one is in two states this one is in
two states two times two is four you
have a nice video about this by somebody
from Righetti describing these states in
terms of bits so you have to think of
that number of doublings each time and
showing that the number of possible bits
doubles every time you add another
coordinate to the bit string
same is true for generic Quantum systems
generic Quantum mini body system
and utilizing many body entanglement
is harder to do
it's not something that these
technologies have really utilized they
have utilized entanglement but they've
utilized entanglement between maybe two
three only a few bodies utilizing really
many body entanglement is something that
only the most recent Quantum
technologies have really been able to do
and some of these of course these are
the ones that are involved in Quantum
Computing and Quantum simulation Quantum
Computing you can probably already
Imagine by the words is that it's a way
to to do some sort of computation to get
a result using a Quantum device using
these four principles that I covered
Quantum simulation is something that's
very similar but it requires less uh
fine-tuned Precision uh the the purpose
of a Quantum simulator is is to design a
mini body Quantum system that can
emulate or simulate another
Quantum system that you're interested in
studying but that is not readily
available in nature it's not quite a
computer it doesn't need to be a
computer because it's not doing some
particular calculation it's not doing
some algorithm uh that that's that's
spitting out necessarily some precise
number it's just trying to simulate
another system that we're interested in
studying so
for many body Quantum systems what are
the ingredients that we usually use well
I mean we just use the ingredients that
are available to us and these are
nothing but atoms
ions
which are just charged atoms photons
or electrons really all we have and so
we stack these up in some way that we
can do what we can control them in some
way we that we can control them and uh
the process of stacking a bunch of these
up and maintaining the level of control
that you need to utilize the four
different uh features of quantum
mechanics that I mentioned is called
scaling up it's very hard these systems
are fragile if you make them super big
they're going to collapse to a classical
State like we humans do right I'm not in
a Quantum superposition as far as I know
right uh where are we now with this uh
it's called n the number of systems here
and we have been able to scale up to
roughly
hundreds of atoms we have about 50 ions
we can do hundreds of photons and
through something called superconducting
circuits we can use Electronics to
construct Quantum systems that have
roughly hundreds of electronic based
qubits now these do utilize electrons
but the jargon that you may want to know
about is
superconducting circuits the reason I
highlight this is because this is sort
of the most dominant technologies that
companies are currently using uh like
IBM and Google
and these Quantum systems are just super
cooled you know circuits with an
inductor and a capacitor and another
thing another sort of inductor that acts
in a in a in a non-linear way relative
to sort of the the way an inductor is
supposed to act just some beefed up
inductor
and these things are cooled these things
are on a chip these things are cooled
these things are small and so they're
Quantum and you can have hundreds of
these on a chip we're very good at
making chips
and this technology is what
has been used to achieve
something with the Quant with one of
these Quantum devices that at least
shows that they are indeed quantum which
is called Quantum Supremacy I remember
from a previous video that qubit is a
Quantum bit
um so would you've mentioned atoms ions
photons electrons and the dominant being
electrons would one say electron be one
qubit is that how it works
no it's unfortunately a lot trickier
than that really the word electrons is
not really used to describe these things
um it's a whole another lecture but uh
so I just think when you say oh we can
say do a hundreds of atoms or we could
do 50 ions I'm just wondering does that
mean hundreds of qubits or 50 do you see
what I mean yes this this little n here
is the number of qubits that are based
off of these of these Technologies okay
I see technology right and in the first
well in the first two cases we do mean
100 there is really one qubit per atom
okay
uh in in one qubit per ion
um because we store things in sort of
the low-lying states of these atoms or
ions
in the case of photons also roughly you
can say that a photon stores a qubit in
the case of electrons you're really
storing information in pairs of
electrons because electrons themselves
are pretty uh you know they're they
behave very differently than than when
they do when they pair up
and uh you basically buy electrons here
I really mean Electronics
Quantum super cool circuits uh like you
know inductors capacitors that we have
in electronics class but they're cold
and small and they utilize another
um another non-linear circuit element
called the Josephus injunction that we
don't utilize in our electrical plugs
so so with the with Quantum Electronics
what has allowed us to achieve uh
Quantum advantage or Quantum as it was
originally called Quantum Supremacy
which is just roughly
the ability of a Quantum system to
do something faster than a classical one
now I'm not saying it's doing anything
useful but it is doing something
and what does that do if we can show it
well we then we know the system is at
least using some Quantum features right
because otherwise it would be classical
and then we can we can simulate it
classically on a classical computer just
as fast as this Quantum device was doing
so what is the task well again roughly
if we go back to these effects then this
effective collapse allows us to
basically become statisticians so we can
induce a Collapse by looking at the
system from various different directions
and every time we do this we get some
outcomes with some probabilities so we
got a snapshot of the system when we
look at it and we get a bunch of
outcomes
um for each of our subsystems so here we
only have one but you know you can
imagine having 150 and you get 150
different outcomes so that's that when
we do a collapse like this we get a
sample
of outcomes we run this this whole
process again we get another sample so
we can collect statistical data about
our system by looking at it from in
various ways and getting outcomes out
and the types of outcomes the
distribution the statistics of these
outcomes
uh can be used to discern if the system
is really Quantum or if it's just some
random person in inside the quantum
computer flipping coins so I've showed
you four basic features of quantum
mechanics that have been harnessed to
make many different Technologies uh that
some of which we use today and some of
which we hope to use in the future and
listed the technologies that people have
been using so
classical physics hasn't been standing
still
throughout that time there in fact
classical computer scientists and
classical cryptographers have observed
the development of these Quantum
Technologies
and have developed in response new
classical
stuff so for example here in Quantum key
distribution it's a way it allows us to
communicate securely and there is
another algorithm called Shores
algorithm that quantum computers are
most famous for that allows us to break
another protocol that allows us to
communicate classically that you use to
log into your bank called RSA and in
response there's been a new wave of
cryptographic protocols that beat RSA in
the sense that they are
supposed to be or postulated to be
resilient to Quantum attacks so this is
called post Quantum crypto and these are
classical protocols that people attempt
to show are
impossible or very difficult to hack
using a quantum computer and nist is uh
sort of leading the the standardization
of these protocols in the same way that
they were leading the standardization of
the rsa-based classical protocols that
we currently use
on the Computing side
um there's often the quantum algorithms
often use different uh ways to perturb
the system that that basically translate
to different Quantum data structures so
to say but some of these data structures
and some of these processes can actually
be peeled off from the quantum system
and distilled into a classical system
and that
has led to the establishment of quantum
inspired algorithms that classical
computer scientists have developed some
of which wind up beating the initial uh
algorithm that was designed to run on a
quantum computer the beauty of this
large swath of quantum Technologies is
that they allow us to learn new things
about that we can do with classical
systems and so there's this ever present
sort of push and pull
and competition between equanimous and
the people who are able to do classical
Computing and uh classical algorithm
design
um such that
we we help each other become better at
doing certain tasks now sometimes uh
it's you know you you you may become
better at doing a specific task with
some specific number of qubits but you
may not be able to be to overcome this
exponential wall uh that you get with
with some classical algorithms that you
can overcome only with a Quantum
algorithm but in other cases people have
shown that you can indeed overcome the
exponential wall uh using a classical
algorithm only so it's a very nice and
fun time to be in the field because uh
we're not really uh certain of what kind
of power quantum computers can be
harnessed for and uh there's still room
for uh
potentially harnessing them for a lot
more
quantized or discrete energies the word
Quantum even comes from this one simple
system that we can demonstrate this with
is called a particle in a box we can
also think about trying to limit the
probability of success or failure or the
probability of certain extremes I think
we can talk about that later